Sharon's with us in Phoenix to start off
this hour hi Sharon how are you I'm fine
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up Dave my mom passed away in
April and she left an inheritance to me
of of them over $100,000 and I am 64
years old and I'm getting ready to
retire and I was just wondering what you
thought about annuities um
not my favorite we can walk through and
talk about them for a few minutes okay
who's presenting you an annuity um I
called the triple-a okay all right um
well the are you out of debt yes I owe
nothing to nobody
no house or anything nope good for you
why do you know how much is in your nest
egg all I have is they had well I have
about a hundred and fifty thousand on
top of this hundred no that's including
200 I'm sorry okay
all right and you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses out
of that other $50,000 yes okay all right
so we'd set aside some of that and the
rest of it it would be for investing in
and I'm guessing you as you retire
you're going to be receiving a pension
the Social Security and then I do have
two IRAs how much is in those the Reedy
um the one is like uh sixty thousand and
the other one is just a small one of
like five thousand okay and uh didn't
use the juice that I hear you say you're
a teacher did I get that in my head no
I'm I'm not working at this time oh okay
all right so you don't have a pension in
addition to Social Security or the IRS
no okay all right well annuities there
are two types there's fixed annuity and
a variable annuity a fixed annuity is
simply a savings account with an
insurance company and it has a very low
interest rate and it is a horrible place
to park investment money okay never do
that okay the variable annuity is
a way to invest in mutual funds through
an annuity and the reason it's variable
is whatever the mutual funds do is what
that annuity is going to do mm-hmm so
you could just buy the mutual fund
straight on and have the same effect of
that with a lot less commissions and a
lot less fees the annuities pay there's
typically two reasons that people sell
annuities in the financial world
one is the Commission's on them going to
the broker are about four times as much
as a mutual fund so that obviously
motivates them the second reason that
they do is they they're not securities
licensed the person selling and so they
can't sell mutual funds but they can
they have a life insurance license and
so they can sell an annuity it's a way
for them to get around and sell you
through the annuity into a mutual fund
and so a lot of times something like
you're dealing with there it's because
they don't have the proper licenses to
do regular investment stuff so I
recommend you sit down with one of our
endorsed local providers they don't work
for me
but they're people that I endorse that
we have vetted and then the big thing
they have is the heart of a teacher okay
because I want you to really understand
this because these these dollars are
very precious to you right because you
haven't got a ton of money and so we've
got to really be very careful with this
and you know that and so if you're if
you don't have a good base of knowledge
of what this money is going into and you
don't have to go get a master's degree
in finance the good news is it's not
rocket science right but but if you'll
sit down with somebody that can lead you
and teach you then you can sleep at
night okay and not worry about it now if
you're in mutual funds the mutual funds
go up or go down then they go up or go
down that's what the stock market does
well if you're going to leave it alone a
long time and you are you're probably
going to pull some of the income off of
it but I don't rush you I don't want you
draining this account dry well then a
good a series of mutual funds would be a
fine investment there'd be nothing wrong
with that very conservative funds that
aren't as volatile as the overall stock
market then if you wanted to put those
funds inside of a variable annuity
you're going to pay more fees
but they have two or three different
things that are kind of neat that you
may want to consider okay one is is that
it gives you principle protection that
the you will never lose your hundred
thousand mm-hmm no matter what the
market does market right way down and
you you're in there the allocated amount
of time usually five or six seven years
or something and you take your money out
and the markets down to eighty thousand
then you'd still get your hundred so
that's kind of comforting and they're
going to have a floor a minimum amount
that they're going to pay of probably
either five or six percent something
like that so you're at least going to
get that much on the money okay and then
in feed the market does better you'll
get more so it gives you a floor but you
pay extra fees to get those two features
by going through the variable annuity so
what I want you to sit down and do is to
learn and look at the variable annuity
and the the other or just doing regular
mutual funds and then you decide between
the two
after you learn but just go to Dave
Ramsey comm and click on ELP for
endorsed local provider and you'll be
able to sit down with someone that's got
the heart of a teacher and will show you
what you're doing so you understand it
you don't do it because I said do it or
cause somebody else says do it you do it
because you understand it and that's
what you were doing today was searching
out you know information education